el aborto dejaría de ser un derecho
federal en eeuu y cada estado de la
unión americana tendría su propia
legislación al respecto pero este
borrador va mucho más allá este borrador
simplemente dice que no existe el
derecho constitucional ese derecho no
existe por lo tanto los estados están
libres para poder prohibir si quieren
totalmente el aborto y más allá abre el
camino para que el congreso de los eeuu
sea si quisiera pudiera pasar una ley
federal que x viviera al aborto en los
50 estados de los 50 estados
aproximadamente la mitad prohibiría en
el aborto estados tradicionalmente
conservadores como idaho wyoming dakota
del norte y del sur texas arkansas
luisiana mississippi tennessee kentucky
y misurí prohibiría en el procedimiento
de manera inmediata como ya lo hizo
claro ma mientras que no está claro si
en estados como west virginia arizona
alabama michigan wisconsin se volverían
a aplicar prohibiciones que fueron
derogadas con el fallo de 1973 en el
caso de los dos últimos estados sus
gobernadores demócratas han anunciado
que no lo harán pero en arizona y
alabama ya están en vigor políticas más
restrictivas montan a nebraska kansas
iowa indiana ohio carolina del norte y
del sur georgia y florida entrarían en
vigor restricciones desde las 22 semanas
o antes cuando incluso algunas mujeres
desconocen si están embarazadas aunque
va extremadamente complejo porque hay
una quizás una mayoría de personas que
de que estiman que el que el feto o un
ser viviente que necesita la protección
del estado sin embargo las hay ahora y
las otras del otro punto de vista te
dice que el embarazo es una decisión
extremadamente personal en este caso ni
siquiera se permite la terminación del
embarazo porque en caso de rapto o en
caso de violación sexual y que el
gobierno no tiene que meterse en una
decisión tan personal de la mujer la
publicación del borrador de la corte
suprema- filtrado el lunes generó
protestas en todo el país que prometen
continuar hasta que los jueces emitan su
fallo a principios de julio